l'hôpital a du mal à passer aux 35
heures le protocole proposé par
elisabeth guigou a été rejetée par
quatre syndicats une manifestation a été
organisée cet après midi à paris les
manifestants qui pense aussi aux
prochaines élections reportage brigitte
briffaud et karine du mois les agents
des hôpitaux réclame pour la deuxième
fois cette année de nouvelles
négociations sur les 35 heures
ils ne sont pas contre la réduction du
temps de travail mais cette réforme n'a
pas évacué leur malaise et à quelques
semaines des élections présidentielles
ils n'ont pas l'intention de baisser les
bras
ans aujourd'hui je trouve qu'à une
campagne présidentielle c'est pas ça qui
doit arrêter les professionnels de la
santé
parce qu'aujourd'hui on se bat
réellement pour l'accès de tous aux
soins et aucun des candidats qui sont en
place qui sont présents ne se prononce
sur une augmentation des budgets de
l'affronter et c'est aujourd'hui la
seule solution maintenant ils nous
promettent tous à la tv regrettez pas la
bande à 24,8 m on va pouvoir enfin
soigner le malade correctement et
maintenant le roman cgt cftc et fo sud
les 4 syndicats réclament 80 mille
emplois supplémentaires
c'est pratiquement deux fois plus que
les créations prévues dans le protocole
guigou
personnellement j'aurais dû perdre en
berne
d'abord embaucher et apprennent à 35
heures en place on peut pas travailler
dans des conditions comme ça c'est pas
possible ça va il veut plus rien dire
c'est pour cela qu'on veut c'est pouvoir
travailler pour donner aux patients des
ibériques
le cortège s'est dispersé devant le
ministère de la santé avec quelques
incidents sans gravité entre forces de
l'ordre et manifestants
de son côté le gouvernement fera non ce
soir qu'il refuse d'ouvrir de nouvelles
négociations